good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the Radcliffe Institute Harvard's
Institute for Advanced Study my name is
Dan carpenter I'm the Freid professor of
government in the Faculty of Arts and
Sciences and I also serve as director of
social science academic ventures here at
the Radcliffe Institute let me tell you
a little bit about today's events the
deans lecture series at Radcliffe brings
to the Institute leading thinkers in the
sciences the arts the social sciences
and humanities in Diana Taylor today's
guests we are fortunate to have an
individual who spans both the arts and
humanities and does so on both sides
with distinction lecturers represent the
very best in their fields what people
who are leading the way in creative
boundary-pushing scholarship
policymaking and art professor Taylor
will be introduced today by Martin poop
nur Byron and in each of yin professor
of drama and of English and of
comparative literature and chair of the
Committee on dramatics at Harvard
professor Porter is leading the effort
to establish a new Harvard undergraduate
concentration in theater dance and media
which is making its way through the many
layers of approval and the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences but recently received
approval from the faculty Council on
February 25th with that let me introduce
or bring up so the podium up sorry
professor poo Peter thank you
it's a great pleasure indeed to
introduce Donna Taylor University
professor at New York University and
associated with the department's of
performance studies and Spanish there
are several reasons why Donna Taylor
does not need an introduction here today
and one of them is that she's been
coming to Harvard
quite a bit just last year for example
she gave important lecture associated
with the program in folklore and
mythology today she's giving the
prestigious Dean's lecture here at the
Radcliffe Institute and just in a few
months she will be giving a lecture and
workshop at the mounds School of Theatre
and performance research here so this
has several things one that you're very
popular here but I also want you to
notice the variety of these institutions
folklore and mythology theater and
performance and here the
interdisciplinary Dean's lecture that
speaks both to the diversity of Donna
Taylor's work but also to put it
slightly differently the fact that her
work has had an impact on quite a number
of different fields for me personally
that Taylor's has been an ambassador for
the power of performance the need for
performance and the importance of
thinking about performance she's written
about Argentina's dirty war and the
disappeared nationalism and sexuality in
America's colonialism and decolonization
the work of women acts of memory now
these topics are crucial for
understanding any culture anywhere and
this is why many different kinds of
disciplines have approached them and
tackled them
Madonna Taylor has done is to
demonstrate that again and again that
this larger cultural and political
conversation is incomplete if it does
not include an acute attention
to performance how bodies move our
performances are marked by the past and
open possibilities for the future how
they activate texts and exceed them
existing in the charged field between
the archives and the repertoire as one
of her many books puts it so memorably
we are talking about performance in an
expanded field that Taylor might
illuminate demonstrations by children of
the disappeared or she might introduce
the work of a Peru Peruvian theatre
troupe Oregon she might talk about the
televised astrology readings by
Univision personality Walter Mercado or
talk with incisive precision about
responses to 911 this work has been
widely read the celebrated with awards
such as the Joey Calloway a prize for
Best spoken drama or the outstanding
Book Award of the Association for
theater in higher education
they've been anthologized including an
performance studies reader in other
words they've been canonized just as
Dinah Taylor herself has canonized the
work of the performance artists and
writers
she cares most passionately about for
example in the influential anthology and
Latin American theater and performance
stages of conflict Donatella understands
the power of the archive and how to get
into the repertoire there's one other
thing I want to mention and that is
institution building because that's work
that's often unrequited and is a lot of
work as we all know and here well in a
way a lot of Don Taylor's work can be
described as making a large argument
about what she calls a hemispheric
perspective in 2003 she wrote now is the
time for remapping the Americas and
that's precisely what she has done not
only through her scholarly
work or anthologies are teaching but
also by creating the hemispheric
Institute which you all know it's an
incredibly important inventive an
innovative Institute that brings
together scholarship and art and this is
of course one of the things that we at
Harvard right now are trying to figure
out for example through the new
concentration in theater dance and media
and hears and many other things we have
much to learn from Donna Taylor which is
why we keep inviting her back today she
will guide us through Sao Paulo's
phantasmagoric and labyrinthine world of
things Donna thank you very much for
coming again please take us into the
labyrinth
thank you very much I want to thank Dean
Cohen of Radcliffe Institute and then
carpenter Martin of course Rebekah
Wasserman and Paul burnin for making
this such a wonderful event so today I'm
going to talk to you about the labyrinth
of things I just need to see if I have a
yes I have a good G okay great great so
I'm going to start with a quote from a
properties poem that's called trash at
dawn it seems as if culture consists in
deeply martyring matter and pushing it
through a relentless gut it's a
consolation to think that not even
excrement can be forced to leave the
planet so this epigraph suggests that
matter
although martyred by constant change and
transformation resists disappearance
this tension between shape-shifting and
durability goes to the crux of and even
extends my thinking about archives
repertoires and distill digital systems
of transmission about what circulates
what we presume remains and what we
assume disappears from culture since the
archons served as the place where
official documents were filed and stored
in ancient Greece the archive has been
synonymous with governmental order
literally cementing the mandate for
preservation and access albeit
restricted of certain materials Western
societies have privileged the archives
with myths of neutrality and stability
and endurance as if things in them don't
change as if things not in them have no
staying power clearly many subversive
and anti-government materials have been
preserved in archives the archives of
the Inquisition
much of what we know about 17th century
practices in Mexico for example
including the non normative sexual
practices listed as sins and perversions
but my point goes more to the
observation posited in the opening
epigraph it's actually hard to get rid
of things perhaps we could question the
politics of visibility that disappears
the ongoingness of practices peoples and
things not destined for the archive when
we look around us at everything from
teeming cities we recognize from teeming
cities full of people to all the
discards that refuse to evaporate from
city dumps we recognize that things do
not in fact disappear they exist in a
constant state of transformation and
again this that observation might alter
how we think of things in a recent
article entitled save as the archive in
the age of digital technologies I
defined the archive a simultaneously an
authorized place the physical or digital
site housing collections a thing /
object or collection of things the
historical records or unique
representative representative objects
marked for inclusion and a practice the
logic of selection organization access
and preservation over time the themes
certain objects archivable place object
practice function in mutually sustaining
ways the object is nameable storable and
preservable imbued with the power and
authority perhaps even aura of both
place and selection we know the thing is
important because it has been elected
for preservation in the archive it does
not matter whether the object was meant
to be saved carbon copies of letters and
even daily newspapers or handouts and
the protests take on the special status
in the archive in turn notions of
historical accuracy of authenticity
authorship property including of course
copyright hold on I'm using this little
thing which is not the best specialized
knowledge expertise and cultural
relevance even truth are under written
by faith in the object found in the
archive this circular legitimating
system again affirms the centrality of
place place object practice exists in a
tightly bound connection in which each
relies on the other for its authority in
that essay I use things and objects
twice in conjunction not as
interchangeable as I know they are not
but connected with a slash thickness as
an object's first took me to the archive
now thickness as a practice unexpectedly
took me back to performance the after
divisions Bourne Trudeau won't proceed
Oh 958 meters
leaders on a walk through South Paulus
phantasmagoric world of things things in
this performance revolve around fabric
things such as dresses and fine claws
sold in shopping malls things such as
the homeless people's blankets and torn
wedding gowns things such as remnants of
cloth and used clothing tossed in
garbage cans and containers things in
there devolve Inglourious use and
decomposition theaters of Artesia
directed by Antonio de Ojo gradually
introduces us into a deeply disturbing
experience we hold on by a proverbial
thread that leads through this
examination of materiality the thickness
of cloth its history politics the people
that make it and the people that it
makes after gathering at the as well the
Andhra G cultural centre in the
immigrant working-class neighborhood of
Andhra thedo spectators are handed a map
with instructions to the meeting place
turn left
after leaving the building cross
Lubavitch Street and go down four more
blocks and then turn left before
arriving at our destination 259
professor society Lombroso Street as we
stand in front of a shopping mall called
shut the buildings and the street names
I figure tell us part of the history the
early Jewish emigration to this
neighborhood shop Arlo's equivalent of
New York Lower East Side Oswald and Raji
the great Brazilian modernist poet and
playwright of the early 20th century
argued in his manifesto anthropophagi
the cannibal manifesto the cultures
remain strong by eating and digesting
others quote only cannibalism unites us
socially economically philosophically
Lombroso
the 19th century Italian born
criminologist
a new genesis eugenicist stated that
criminality was passed down through
generations and could be recognized
through physiognomy the locations
themselves then suddenly revealed
terrifying theories of transmission
cemented into the very geography of
place and practice shop signs in Korean
tell of new waves of immigrants that
mostly the replace the now well-off Jews
who moved off to better residential
areas the ultra-orthodox
and Hasidic Jews stayed behind while
Libyans now working for the Koreans or
the new lowest of the low the
neighborhood the names the signs the
remnants of cloth suggests that this is
a state of constant change transition
circulation absorption and regurgitation
the evening streets are eerily empty
sixty to eighty people can attend the
performance it's dark and we wind our
way in groups of twos and threes through
the uneven sidewalks of narrows
the shops are shuttered closed at this
time of night
garbage bags tilt against streetlights
at each corner where are we going see if
I can make this work
yeah the unknown dark URI landscape
already feels like part of the
performance I know this various pieces
of fabric bursting out of garbage cans
there are things left over from other
things dresses pants jackets walking
further I detect something strange about
the street lines did I die we shall
really alter them I'm concerned about an
elderly woman who walks beside me an
artist from Mexico I had met previously
I worried for her on the treacherous
sidewalks and hold onto her arm what if
she falls and breaks something is the
artesian Leibel life is risky walking
down the street is risky but still is
this a part of the performance I stopped
to look at something written on the wall
is that part of the performance
everything takes on a new intentionality
all the random bits and pieces of
everyday life seem aligned or assembled
in a special order inviting us to
decipher them when I turn back to walk
the old woman has gone I see her ahead
of me
single-mindedly moving towards the
performance site
finally everyone converges at the
designated place the street is dim and
desolate there's not much happening
really except a woman sitting in a chair
in front of a shuttered indistinct
shopping mall listening to the radio all
we hear is the crackle of the static
suddenly workers delivering boxes of
merchandise come crashing down the
street besties as they Carnival or
beasts of burden the text calls them
soon shoppers carrying large bag bags
join them hammering the door to get in
they all line up and pause in front of
the large metallic door that covers the
shopping mall before pushing it open
that pause a tableau vivant captures the
anticipation of the before and after
that all-powerful moment of exchange of
goods in capitalism suddenly gloriously
the lights from the mall spills over us
like daybreak sonorous rumblings herald
us inside we have been inaugurated into
the temple of things it everything is
alive the lights and music pulsate
an invisible hand guides us deeper and
deeper into the dark maze of the
shopping mall we have entered into the
belly of the monster the next two hours
spectators experience the vertiginous
pole and push of things I say things
instead of objects because object
suggests a degree of phenomenological
stability a chair is a chair you can
label a chair and put it in the archive
objects according to w JT Mitchell are
the way they are the way things appear
to the subject and quote
they are nameable categorizable things
on the other hand are more ambiguous
they conjure a process transformation
and substitutability the chair thing is
a tree wood planks splinters junk a
weapon or instrument firewood but it can
also be the memory of my home and almost
anything else we can imagine Bill Brown
notes that the word thing indexes a
certain limit or liminality to hover
over the threshold between the nameable
and the unnameable the figural and the
unfavorable the identifiable and the
unidentifiable I can use thing to speak
of another thing one thing leads to
another
so here - spectators participate in a
journey that follows the logic of things
as we enter one area it magically lights
up
space seems full of wonder and I look
around like an aging Miranda in this
strange new environment it glitters the
things in it glitter who is pulling the
strings but as the audience audience
members begin to move through the
shadowy environment I noticed that it's
shabby the tawdry things and the wannabe
upscale shopping mall take on a sudden
luminance then fade again I'm confused
about what is part of the performance
and what is not
does this more function during the day
as a real mall or is it a set for the
performance are those things in the
display windows real merchandise does
the performance stand in for the real or
add another level of practice and
another lens for perception I try to
resist the temptation to move you
through the performance and the
spectacular ways in which our DeLucie
conjures up the magical world of things
in capitalism I gave up walking through
the performance entails its own way of
knowing and the beauty and brilliance of
Bhangra the--do performs its own
analysis of the desperation of a
population subjugated to things as
things cannot be understood
phenomenologically there's no such thing
as a thing they need to be understood in
context and practice is the piece of
cloth a coveted shawl or a discard this
is not the theatrical icing of the of
archive ation as in daily does word but
it's opposite the shape-shifting that
exceeds the archive but is not quite the
repertory alive the only way I could
start thinking about the complexities
the performance opens up was by moving
through it here I will retrace my steps
to offer my own process of analysis as a
spectator having been sucked into this
familiar space a mall in the strangest
of ways we follow a lone woman she stops
an illuminated shop to stare at a red
dress it clearly
obsesses her the stores are always
closed the consumer Loida complains you
have to get here earlier a lot earlier
you should sleep here the red dress
replies lights in the shops pulse
audience members squeeze to the next
place to look at the action I begin to
feel the stress of constant vigilance
the relentless one-day thrust of the
seemingly chaotic performance makes me
feel as if I'm being pushed to a rhythm
the contraction releases the combination
of being on guard and pushed forward
puts me in a state of tunnel vision I
scan the environment to assess the risks
and prioritize what to focus on where is
that old woman ghostly mannequins lined
the passage the passageways one holding
a grande grande promotion a sign seems
alive she is alive as the corridor
lights up ahead the one behind goes dark
the experience is not frightening really
but it's bewildering it conjures up the
environment of terror
I have lived since 9/11 the mandate to
stay alert coupled with the confusion of
not knowing what is real or dangerous or
threatening and what isn't if you see
something say something
do you bicker this mass transit warnings
of the New York area you stare a
relatively new phenomenon a u.s. import
like some of the things in the store or
do I carry it now with me wherever I go
it's hard to gauge what matters and what
doesn't to know what to look at or what
I've missed
after some time I notice that anonymous
ninja like humans clad head-to-toe in
fabric move both the lighting and sound
systems along with us they manage our
environment silently and invisibly
transforming it the invisible ization of
labour and capital performed by those
shrouded figures it's not clear that
they're always the same hue
but they like the mannequins look the
same and function interchangeably
everything around us is animated but not
necessarily alive the shadow figures
like seemingly all else here are
governed by the capitalist logic of
things as substitutable discardable and
replaceable as opposite to archives that
consider objects as unique and worthy of
preservation humans are only partially
awake things mannequins are not dead
any more than the shadow figures are
truly alive instead of a brave new world
we've entered into a whole new world now
sung by the action era philosophica the
afro-brazilian cleaning woman she sings
about the new as she recycles the Disney
song and dust off the sign that reads
doping Center instead of shopping center
the female African descendant in use to
clean where have I seen this before the
slave trade gave rise to a complex
network of relations all sustained on
and through the body that could be
signified and sold slavery the savage
violence of exchange constitutes the
inaugural act of capitalism which grew
out of the trade in humans terror to
answer my earlier reflection has always
been the underside of capitalism and the
trading cotton textile specifically
sustained the circular system in which
quote the product of Italian weavers
paid for slaves in Africa to work on
plantations in the Americas to produce
agricultural commodities for your
European consumers as your colleagues
van Barrett wrote in the empire of
cotton a defective male mannequin that
you can see here manufactured in Korea
finds it hard to believe she's not as
gorgeous as those on display trash they
call her she
nothing but trash most shop windows on
our journey are dark and shut tight but
once in a while we see something inside
the shops Bolivian women working through
the night sewing the red dress that
other women will wear the thing off'
occation of humans especially of women
partying proposes continues long after
slavery has been officially eradicated a
female actors actor plays radio infinita
the radio that never sleeps for workers
who never sleep the radio is a person
thing her eyes or transistors and ten I
pop up from her head but she she is live
but certainly not alive offering 50% of
sales talking to this world of dreams
sponsored by clonazepam the manufacturer
of sleeping pills yet radio radio
infinite US announcements also carry
terror alerts we hear that the recent
attacks are being investigated and those
are partly responsible punished the
terror presumably leads to more shopping
therapy and a greater demand for
sleeping pills and negocio redondo as we
call it in Mexico so it's a full circle
business in the corridors a delivery man
fondles a female mannequin at times the
audience follows behind a happy group of
shoppers running towards a fire exit ana
dante a disruptive terrorist figure
intervenes at different moments at this
point in the action an enormous
floor-to-ceiling banner goes up in
flames he goes running off what I see is
stunningly beautiful and utterly
depressing at the same time I'm trapped
in the system or a machine or an
organism that I cannot assess but that
pushes me along the experience has no
outside no external place that dirty
diet tributes to archives no place from
which to name and categorize the rush of
things that engulf and move us we move
through
haunted spaces of circulation and
exchange an empty mall full of wants and
longings desire transports us to a space
of imagined future being or having want
steals our present what gets preserved
in the world is not the object but the
desire the desire to own a character in
the play tells us that we're in the room
in the realm of the book tronic a devil
of things without owners originally a
malevolent clinging character from
Jewish mythology if anything things own
us and make us one of them one more
thing among things the living model has
now been marked down again she is now
30% off many cultures believe that
things have a life of their own
the Mayans both ancient and contemporary
have a word to Lin for the animation in
all things human and non-human to Lin
refers to the life in everything its
grandeur this differs radically from the
shopping mall in which humans and
everything else and become deadened
there to Lily the Mayans might say has
been stolen or broken people become
lifeless things like mannequins
capitalist exigencies and lack of
opportunity push people from place to
place like migrants people here are
broken down to body parts arms and backs
to pick the grapes or push the baby
carriages they are interchangeable and
disposable racism violence against women
and generalized doping further hue
dehumanize we are all displaced this
performance suggests as it takes us on a
tour of the underside of things the
performance further underscores this by
using some 30 or so actors to play the
hundreds of figures and shadows that
populate this universe everyone quite
literally is always morphing into
something or someone else
our journey through the maze is
interrupted by bangs and screams the
drug-addicted homeless population
outside the mall beats on the metal
gates demanding to be let in again at
our show stages that tableau vivant at
the locked entrance to the mall the
addicts with blankets thrown over their
shoulders to keep them warm posed as
mirror images of the consumers and
delivery people at the beginning of the
performance they too belong to the
crazed world of demand and supply theirs
is a universe of rocks
Vedran crack I am also a person please
the Calico mono trying to sell stuff to
the shoppers and audience his small
bedroom is his all he has in crocolandia
foundation - he's more images the mall
and cata Qalandia it's the degree to
which people live in interconnected
economies the violence outside and the
privatized violence inside the gates
though those connections are often
obscured but again a rush of activity
makes it impossible to hold on to a
reflection all of a sudden the crowd of
consumers overtakes us they rip off
their old clothes and throw them to the
floor they rush out of the building
euphoric with her new acquisitions
trampling over all the cloth on the
ground the audience too walks over the
discarded fabric on the way out fabric
has a complicated history I looked down
where I'm stepping the blankets over the
shoulders of the crack addicts like the
blankets on the shoulders of survivors
of concentration camps reminds us that
there's a politics to cloth an economy a
social performance of value instead
disappeared people in Peru have been
identified through small remnants of
clothing I follow them out of the mall
walking on the textiles and I feel I'm
being asked to witness another kind of
violence and disappearance we follow the
shoppers the homeless and other members
of the audience out of the mall and into
the dark passageway between buildings
despite our many differences for a
moment we're all the same we are all the
people who move through spaces that
don't belong to us transitional spaces
that don't belong to anyone the move to
the dark outside is far less noticeable
than the initial entry into the mall
even though the shadow figures accompany
us there is no music no glorious light
just the sound of a train passing very
close by did I die we shall plan that
the performance consists of
interconnected threads acts themes
characters colors sounds and images that
repeat and different patterns throughout
the piece the outside resembles the
inside far more than we might have
anticipated the nodes highpoints
undersides flashes poses are all they're
redistributed rather infinita continues
speaking terror continues to threaten
our dreams distractions interrupt our
knowing looking up at the dark windows
of the silent buildings we see the
silhouettes of women sewing at their
machines a bride in a crumpled wedding
dress appear standing on the high narrow
ledge of wall
she's the wall she tells us she was
looking for a store and doesn't know how
she got trapped on that ledge or how to
get off now the shadowy figures move all
their equipment on carts as they run in
front of us or beside us the consumidor
de wanders in the street homeless now -
looking for the clothes shop with a red
dress audience members walk walk by
smashed mannequins and other refuse that
refuse that lies abandoned on the
sidewalks the shadowy figures push
female mannequins down the streets in
carts and glass boxes
thing mobiles we're Mainers objects on
display on route to the secret
disintegrating into things as we
approach a crowd a crowded City Avenue
two women notice that they're wearing
the same red outfit in rage they claw
and rip at each other until they're both
stark naked
the women stop and look at each other
again jump into each other's arms and
kiss but this is not a passionate kiss
they are joined not by desire but by the
thread that links us all it's literally
unraveling between their mouths
unraveling from their mouths is they
back away from one another a bus passes
by with curious passengers peering out
of the windows did I lose your stage
that it's a real bus those are real
people
I assure myself aware of how foolish I
sound even to myself further down the
street young arrogant model strut down a
runway showing off their designer
clothing we're in the middle of an
Avenue in South Paulo without seeming to
pay attention they expertly dodge buses
cars and bicycles as they sashay back
and forth trampling the antique
indigenous weavings that serve as the
carpet under their feet the city too is
a protagonist a living organism only now
am i beginning to grasp the scale of the
performance everything happens at the
same time we hear airplanes trains buses
and everything becomes part of something
else and not least the performance we're
a part of
we're in traffic not just street traffic
but also the traffic and drugs in women
in undocumented labor pirate radio the
traffic and dreams and desires every
everything like the cloth is in the
process of decomposition position
recomposition and being discarded we're
part of the performance of
transformation and transmutation the
cannibalism of capitalism that unites us
desire is part of the process moves
things along in this dream world
it appears that the inexorable process
will lead to the accusation of the ideal
thing rather than to death before after
ad shows a fat man as before and a
smiling slim man after the ear aunty
surreptitiously replaces the image of
the slim man with one of a cadaver
desire leads us does not lead us where
we think we are going a bike pulls a
cart in which a naked delivery man is
now his beloved mannequin we
keep walking down the city streets
crossing avenues and catching sight of
things that may or may not have been
designed for the performance after a
while it doesn't matter I think it's a
co-production Antonia de Ojo verities
iam in the city of Sao Paolo audience
members tried to be attentive to each
other although we're part of the
experience were also atomized we can't
really walk together the performance
pulls us this way in that shadow figures
moving the sound and lighting equipment
chef's past us consumers rushed through
the corridors in the mall and then on
the streets as we watch for cars and
buses the sound of the subway makes us
turn in short were part of the frenzy we
too are pushed by desire or desire to
see and experience and make sense of
this environment that looks so foreign
and familiar at the same time even
though the actions sounds and lighting
position everyone so we can get a better
look we are always part of the show
moving in it and through it well their
team creates astonishing images I will
argue that this is not a performance at
four grounds the image rather it's about
the image making society that the board
writes about the society of the
spectacle in which the social relations
among people is mediated by images the
breathtaking tableau capture the thing
for a second display it in a light box
so we can see it then releases it again
into the crash of circulation we will
never see it
same way again while we rush to get a
glimpse of something our inner our inner
Debord chides us for being enthralled by
images yet says our inner Heraclitus but
even these are never the same twice
we Crane our necks trying to see what's
just outside the frame of vision there
is no privileged spectator in this
performance the image making machine is
way beyond our control no frame or stage
or archive could contain it it has too
many moving parts as we walk on some
local fleeing out of their windows
looking at their Street made strange
knowing that for a moment they to form
part of the performance they looked at
they look at us amusing objects of their
gaze I look up at them looking at me
again I am overwhelmed by a sense of
risk seemingly unprotected in the streak
now following the actors and focusing on
the action there's a lot to look out for
something could happen the bride appears
trapped on another ledge this time the
startling beauty of the tableau makes me
forget the vulnerability of looking up
and around even as I walk down the city
street the crack addict moves his
bedroom now growing increasingly
unwieldly at one moment he shouts out I
don't want to hear about obligatory
internment in reference to a law that
had passed in Brazil in early 2013
requiring internment and rehabilitation
for addicts the light and sound cues
prompt us a stop and start the living
model now 60% now 90% off stands in the
middle of the street without a word we
are pressed to keep moving we only move
one way forward without a sense of
progress when we stopped in front of a
multi-story building my spectator Claude
tells me we're approaching the end we
stand facing the building's multi-story
glass facade each window is a mini stage
people move inside things happen I now
feel like a consumer at the peep show
when
just a few blocks back I felt like an
amusing object for the locals looking
out of their windows object viewing
subject consumer critic amazed
audience member cautious pedestrian all
describes certain watching and looking
experiences I've had during the evening
but now we've stopped moving and we're
looking up at the large multi set stage
of sorts so I expect the performance to
end some culminating scene will make all
the threads evidence and it will be over
then the doors open and the woman from
the beginning of the performance asurs
us into a large 4ei of a building in
disrepair we sit on the stairs looking
forward like in a traditional audit our
audience photocopies of old Yiddish
theater fliers litter the stairs some of
the characters appear there's a flexion
at the philosophic again cleaning as
ever we sit and wait is this the end
after everyone is congregated guides
lead us downstairs to a very large
completely disintegrated Theatre people
in wheels and wheel chairs are DeLucie
tells me later our carried down we enter
into the world of red it's dark and
everyone is careful as they look and
feel for a place to sit the red plush
velvet of the seats remind us that this
was once a place with aspirations of its
own in its prime the theatre was part of
a Jewish Cultural Center a stronghold of
the resistance to the dictatorship now
in now in disrepair people have
forgotten about it
the consumidor de continues her search
for the red dress suddenly the room is
full of shadow figures in red dresses
their faces covered in red cloth they
ceremoniously embrace her put the dress
on her cover her face and welcome her
into the deadened world of things as in
the mall an enormous piece of fabric
goes up in flames the Attic comes back
now melded
this rock it's one of my organs one of
my limbs he yells only surgery can
separate us the audience is invited
upstairs throughout the entire forum
performance everything moves and SEC
circulates again I think of the risk and
watch my stairs the watch my step the
stairs are so rickety I wonder how the
older artists from Mexico is getting on
at the same time the beauty the images
are there was a composers fill me with
awe standing on stage looking back
through the theater we see the exquisite
tableau three Bolivian women continue to
sew the fabric each isolated in her
circle of momentary light and visibility
we are united in our atomization perhaps
this is the exact opposite of the
Chilean certainly this must be the end
of the performance it's not that I want
the performance to end
I'm completely caught up in it but it
feels as if the movement and circulation
will lead to closure the rhythm of the
piece itself seems to demand a full stop
but no as soon as I formulate the
thought chaos breaks out again a hint
it's a neat ideas come into the theatre
with their long brushes and
disinfectants the space fills with
sounds and clashes and thumping and
yelling at the NCR do not panic evacuate
the area the sound of sirens and alarms
punctuate the words coming from
loudspeakers the audience is
unceremoniously expelled as workers hose
down the floor around our feet we like
things are put through the process of
circulation and disgorged at the end
we've been pushed through the gut of the
beast and expelled let's be polite and
say we've been regurgitated the
Sanitation crew cleans up behind us on
the street immediately in front of us we
see a large dumpster filled with the
broken figures we've come to know
throughout the living model now 100
percent off so so there too is the
defective model and the fractionate a
philosophica it's painful to see the
women lying
broken undone by the endless violence of
signification if they were just things I
think the defective mannequin continues
to chat away happily about things
choices although her limbs are ask you
these dismembered bodies did not
comprise a corpus the assemblage points
to the differences between the dumpster
of trash and an archive a corpus is a
well-defined categorized body of work
each piece organized and understood in
relation to the others
the trash pile is a site of human
decomposition as we all walk past them
the large crew begins to gather on the
street ready to take their bow they
thank Petrobras Brazil's petroleum
company for the financial support they
need to produce this play by law Petrova
Petrobras is and has the last word but
behind us the woman from the beginning
of the play looks at us enigmatic Allah
is this really the end the arrogant
posts a banner announcing one more fire
sale capitalism never ends we all
disperse into the night going back the
next day in daylight I see many of the
same elements I remember from the
performance yes the mall functions and
the stores are now open for business as
usual most of them selling knock-off
designs of something in fashion who
knows where homeless people lined the
sidewalks some of them pull carts full
of their personal belongings I realized
that the Forgotten theater at the end
sits right around the corner from the
OSA Valdai dandrige a center where we
had started we had come round full
circle there was no destination no
ending just circulation
transmission regurgitation by the end of
the performance my theory of things and
archives and my sense of self as
subject/object product of late
capitalism had been churned through the
belly of the monster and came out